i
[Música]
ah
yo bailén cumplió una de sus promesas de
campaña al reconocer el genocidio
armenio y la comunidad de armenios
estadounidenses que cercan al millón de
personas en este país ha reaccionado de
forma positiva el académico surgen ships
jean dijo que todas las familias
armenias tienen ancestros que murieron
en las masacres históricas que esto es
muy importante sin embargo dijo que el
reconocimiento no es vinculante
legalmente y no llevará a ninguna
compensación por su parte kim kardashian
armenia estadounidense también agradeció
a bailén y dijo que después de un siglo
de pelea por la verdad hoy el pueblo
armenio recibe el reconocimiento que
estaba esperando
nicholas kristof periodista armenio del
'new york times' y dos veces ganador del
pulitzer price dijo que es grandioso ver
el reconocimiento aunque se haya
demorado
hay que mencionar que en el 2019 el
senado ya había aprobado de forma
unánime una resolución reconociendo el
genocidio
[Música]
tanto en armenia como en el resto de las
comunidades
fue recibido con gran optimismo el
reconocimiento del genocidio armenio por
parte del presidente de los eeuu joe
biden
luego de largos años de estar esperando
que los ex mandatarios de este país
también pronunciarán el término
genocidio para calificar las masacres de
1915 el gobierno de armenia sostuvo que
este reconocimiento es un ejemplo
inspirador para todos aquellos que
quieran construir sociedades justas
tanto el primer ministro niccoló para
chillán como el presidente de armenia
armen sarkisián manifestaron que con
este reconocimiento no sólo se rinde
homenaje a las 1 millón 500 mil víctimas
sino también se evita que crímenes de
lesa humanidad como éste vuelvan a
ocurrir
[Música]
la inmensa mayoría de los turcos están
en contra del reconocimiento de este
sábado pasado por parte del presidente
de eeuu en delray genocidio armenio
ocurrido en la península de anatolia
durante el año 1915 cerca de 189 por
ciento según algunos sondeos estipulan
el porcentaje de turcos que si acepta
que hubo tal genocidio reconocido por la
gran mayoría de expertos e historiadores
internacionales de hecho casi ningún
partido turco ha aceptado ya le han
gustado las palabras debaten sólo uno el
partido prokurdo tercero en el
parlamento jefe está a favor de
reconocer dicho genocidio la gran
mayoría el 99 por ciento de los demás
partidos están absolutamente en contra y
han hablado de que la decisión de joe
biden es una decisión populista y que
ellos totalmente rechazan
[Música]